i'm going to carry on right from this
line now put your pens down for a second
this proof is proof it's so
mind-bogglingly fast that you can
see it written down and follow every
step
and it'll be over before you say wait
what just happened
how did did that just really do what i
thought it did okay so i'm going to go
through it super slow it's not that much
to write
okay let's look at this line here this
line that i've set out okay
let me ask you two questions number one
for what values of
n is this statement true you know we
looked at
extraneous solutions in algebra and that
kind of thing sometimes statements are
true for some values of
x or whatever and some it's not what
values of n is this true for
i've got a couple of restrictions so far
at least um first i want n to be
positive
right because if it's negative i'm
getting fractions and it's not going to
happen
right um secondly i'm thinking like this
is all in integer length right
it's all an integer length i haven't
explored what happens when you look at
my fractions and all that kind of thing
but i'm expecting if m was say equal to
a half
this is going to be square root right it
doesn't look like it's going to pan out
for me okay so i'm saying
is a fancy way of writing it and has to
be
a positive integer don't get messed up
on the notation
if you're like well i've never seen that
before that's what it means i'm telling
you what it means
n is an integer that's positive
that's what it means okay all right so
there's there's a restriction on n
what about x for what values of
x is this statement true
let's think about that for a second okay
so you're looking at a polynomial here
right let's not just think of you know
part of the problem this
is it's abstracting like what is this
really well i've got an actual one right
here this is a polynomial
maybe if you want to look at this one
for what values of x
is that statement true because i'll take
an n out of the equation though yeah
do you mean like this number at the
front here
let me pose that question to everyone
because i think you may have looked at
some questions like this
if i say this
what difference does that make you just
yeah well so where i have x here
oh 2x where x squared here i'll have
2x or squared right and then i'll have
2x all cubed still kind of works
um the one three three one that pattern
still forms let me put something to you
i think this statement is true for all
values of x
i think it's always true even when you
put in weird wacky stuff into there
you think of a kind of number positives
negatives
irrationals transcendence any number you
like
you can put this in here you can chuck
it into your calculator go for it go
go one plus pi cubed okay
i'm going to put some money down that
it's equal to 1 plus 3 pi
plus 3 pi squared plus pi cubed whatever
that's equation
okay i'm putting to you that this is
always true
so therefore i'm going to take a very
pedestrian value of x
i'm going to say how about x
equals 1 that's a pretty ordinary number
right let's just see what happens before
i do the left hand so i'm going to do
the right hand side that's a bit weird
what's gonna happen over here on the
right hand side one is important one is
useful
one has some properties when you raise
it to a power right because one to the
power of
naught is going to be one
and uh one to the power of one is gonna
be one and one squared
and one cubed and one to the n right you
get it i'm multiplying
doesn't do anything so in fact all i get
left with is the
coefficients right
refocus
are you happy with my right hand side so
far can you see i've just
not written a whole bunch of ones okay
okay fine
what does the left-hand side look like
what just happened i told you i told you
it would go by so fast
that you hardly even noticed have you
ever seen
have you ever seen a one-line proof in
your life
there he is